[Musik]
SALLY: Hallo! Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Jetzt, wenn die heißen Tage überhandnehmen,
finde ich, wird es mal wieder Zeit
für ein selbstgemachtes Eis.
Mein Team hat sich ein Kinder-Pingui-Eis gewünscht.
Das geht auch sehr schnell.
Das Einzige, was lange dauert, ist natürlich das Einfrieren.
Aber das kann man ja über Nacht machen
oder einfach für vier bis fünf Stunden.
Ich werde jetzt Eis am Stiel machen.
Ich habe dafür diese Eiswürfel-
– nicht Eiswürfel –
diese Eis-am-Stiel-Förmchen.
Ihr könnt aber auch ganz gerne eine große Form nehmen
oder ganz andere Förmchen,
was ihr eben so dahabt.
Für das Eis verwende ich
300 Gramm Joghurt,
– da nehme ich jetzt einen Sahnejoghurt mit 10 % –
30 Gramm Puderzucker,
etwas Vanilleextrakt,
200 Gramm Sahne
und acht Kinder Pingui.
Ja, Sahnejoghurt deshalb,
weil der einfach schon schön cremig ist.
Und ihr könnt natürlich zum Beispiel
auch Quark nehmen oder Mascarpone.
Aber Joghurt hat einfach so eine andere Säure,
die perfekt dazu passt.
Deswegen nehme ich das sehr, sehr gerne.
Vom Geschmack her wird das Ganze
wie diese Ice Cream Rolls.
Da wird ja auch eine Eisgrundmasse gemacht
und dann zerkleinert auf so einer Eisplatte
und dann eben gerollt.
Und so ähnlich wird das dann schmecken.
Weil da machen die ja auch ganz oft
eben Süßigkeiten mit dazu.
Und deswegen bei mir die Version Kinder Pingui.
Vanilleextrakt rein
und Sahne.
Ihr seht auch, das ist sehr, sehr einfach.
Und dann die Zutaten kurz cremig verrühren.
[Musik]
So sieht das jetzt aus.
Und da kommen jetzt die Kinder Pingui rein.
Ich nehme jetzt alle acht.
Wie macht man die auf?
Ach, ich mache hier.
Ich dachte, da gibt es so einen Aufreißer.
[Musik]
Und dann einfach zerstampfen.
Wenn ihr jetzt die Eismasse probiert,
sollte sie leicht zu süß sein.
Denn durch das Abkühlen und Einfrieren
verliert sich die Süße so ein bisschen.
Das heißt, hier darf es wirklich einen Ticken zu süß sein.
Mach A.
JOSH: A.
Mmh!
SALLY: Ist okay?
Aber es kommt ja noch Schokolade.
JOSH: O ja. Ja.
SALLY: Genau.
Dann habe ich jetzt hier diese Eis-am-Stiel-Förmchen.
Und das sind einfach Silikonformen.
Aus denen bekomme ich das Eis perfekt wieder raus.
Ansonsten könnt ihr dieses Eis
aber auch zum Beispiel in eine Kastenform einfüllen,
in eine Silikonkastenform oder in eine Glaskastenform.
Bei der Glaskastenform
einfach Frischhaltefolie dazwischenlegen.
Und jetzt hier einfach schön reinfüllen
und glatt streichen.
Kennt ihr noch dieses
– es gibt dieses Eis, was aussieht wie eine Torte
und so länglich, und dann schneidet man da so Stücke runter.
JOSH: Viennetta heißt das.
SALLY: Viennetta, ja. Und so kann man es auch machen.
Dann kann man sich so Stücke runterschneiden.
[Musik]
Ich wollte eigentlich das Ganze
mit einem Löffel abfüllen.
Da sagt der Josh:
"Wie? Kein Eisportionierer?!"
Und dann habe ich gesagt: "Ja, okay, komm.
Einmal muss ich es ja auch mal
zum Eisportionieren benutzen, oder?"
JOSH: Ja.
SALLY: Ha ja.
Jetzt hier und dann schön glatt streichen.
Ich glaube, ich ziehe das einfach so glatt.
[Musik]
Das ist es, was fehlt.
Siehst du?
[Musik]
Und dann nehmt ihr einfach diese Holzstäbchen,
die Eisstiele, steckt sie rein.
Und dann kommt das Eis in den Gefrierschrank,
am besten über Nacht.
[Musik]
Tag zwei!
Das Eis ist gefroren!
Und jetzt wird es dekoriert.
Entschuldigt meine müden Augen.
Es ist noch sehr früh am Morgen.
Und vielleicht war ich lange weg.
Nein, natürlich nicht.
Ich habe jetzt hier einige Zutaten vorbereitet,
nämlich
Zartbitterkuvertüre,
weiße Kuvertüre,
Chocolate Crispearls in Zartbitter und Weiß
zum Überziehen des Eises.
Und Zartbitterkuvertüre brauche ich jetzt etwa 300 Gramm.
Ich schaue mal, ob es ausreicht,
aber ich denke schon.
JOSH: Sehr elegant.
SALLY: War schon elegant, gell?
Jetzt fragt ihr euch vielleicht:
"Warum hat sie so viele Schälchen?"
Also bei Kuvertüre, Schokolade im Allgemeinen ist es so,
dass ihr diese jetzt schmelzen solltet.
Ich schmelze aber nie alle gleichzeitig.
Denn die Schokolade braucht eine gewisse Temperatur,
nämlich so ungefähr zwischen 29 und 31°C,
je nach Schokosorte.
Und ich mache das dann so:
Zwei Drittel, also 200 Gramm sind hier im Schälchen,
ein Drittel, also 100 Gramm sind hier im Schälchen.
Und ich werde jetzt diese zwei Drittel
über dem warmen,
aber nicht kochenden Wasserbad schmelzen
und dann mit diesem Drittel impfen.
Und deswegen nennt sich diese Methode Impfmethode.
Und dann bekommt die Schokolade
die perfekte Weiterverarbeitungstemperatur
und es kann nichts mehr schiefgehen.
Und ich mache es immer so,
dass ich das Wasser erst mal kochen lasse,
dann den Herd ausschalte.
Denn da reicht die Hitze auf jeden Fall schon mal aus.
Jetzt kann ich hier schon mal die zwei Drittel reingeben.
Bei der weißen Kuvertüre genauso.
Da habe ich ein bisschen weniger.
Die dient gleich der Dekoration.
[Musik]
Und wenn es geschmolzen ist,
vom Wasserbad runternehmen
und dann die feste Schokolade dazu
und schön schmelzen.
Und da reicht, wie gesagt, die Restwärme.
[Musik]
Gut. Während das noch fertig schmilzt...
Ich glaube, hier in die weiße Kuvertüre
gebe ich noch ein bisschen Kokosfett,
einfach, damit sie noch ein bisschen flüssiger wird.
Das will ich nämlich für die Deko benutzen.
Ja. Jetzt kann ich es kurz hier stehen lassen
und schon mal das Eis holen.
[Musik]
So. Und das Eis lässt sich auch wunderbar rauslösen
aus den Silikonformen. Guckt mal.
Einfach hier oben ein bisschen ablösen.
Und dann
von unten nach oben schieben.
Zack!
Kinder-Pingui-Eis am Stiel.
Und mit Stil.
[Tusch]
[Musik]
Ihr könnt auch hier gerne
noch ein bisschen Kokosöl dazugeben,
damit die Kuvertüre ein bisschen dünnflüssiger wird.
Jetzt am besten in ein hohes Gefäß füllen,
also zum Beispiel ein Glas, eine Tasse.
Jetzt müsst ihr natürlich ein bisschen schnell arbeiten.
Denn die Kuvertüre wird schnell fest.
Also eintunken und dann diese Crispearls drauf.
[Musik]
Schon so wie in der Magnum-Werbung.
JOSH: Ja.
SALLY: Ja?
SALLY: Und dann natürlich direkt ein paar Perlchen drauf,
wenn ihr möchtet.
Das mit der weißen Kuvertüre mache ich gleich,
wenn alle fertig sind.
Weil da muss ich jetzt wirklich
Eis für Eis mich durcharbeiten.
[Musik]
Und jetzt könnt ihr noch die weiße Kuvertüre nehmen
und die einfach in so Streifen drübergeben.
Und dann ist das Eis sofort verzehrbereit.
Ich suche mir ein Opfer, das probieren darf.
Ho, ho, ho!
Das nächste Versuchskaninchen! Ho, ho!
Okay, so schlimm ist es nicht.
Okay, manchmal reißen sie sich echt nicht drum,
weil sie sagen so: "Morgens um acht schon Eis?!"
JOSH: Wer sagt das?
SALLY: Ja, gell?
[Musik]
Jetzt ist das Eis fertig und kann verkostet werden.
Heute darf jemand probieren,
den ihr vielleicht schon kennt,
aber noch nicht aus meinen Videos.
Dü-dü-dü-düb, dü-düü!
LINUS: Hallo!
SALLY: Linus!
Herzlich willkommen!
LINUS: Danke schön.
SALLY: Linus kennt ihr vielleicht schon aus der VOX-Doku.
LINUS: Ja,
von dem Papier auf dem Boden.
SALLY: Ja.
Man muss dazu sagen, der Murat...
Kein – ach!
Wir haben da eine gespaltene Meinung darüber.
Ich fand es dumm,
einfach so ein Papierknäuel auf dem Boden.
Murat dachte sich so: "Ja."
Ja.
LINUS: Hm.
Ich habe es nicht gesehen.
SALLY: Den menschlichen Test
und den Fachtest hast du bestanden.
LINUS: Dann bin ich froh.
SALLY: Deswegen bist du da.
Weil du fachkompetent
und menschlich ein hervorragender Mensch bist.
LINUS: Ach, danke schön!
SALLY: Gell? Deswegen.
LINUS: Das freut mich.
SALLY: Ja.
Und heute darfst du das erste Mal vor der Kamera probieren.
Hinter der Kamera hat er schon öfter probiert.
LINUS: Das stimmt. Ja, schon einiges.
SALLY: Komm ruhig näher. Ich beiße nicht.
LINUS: Ja, okay.
SALLY: Noch nicht.
LINUS: Noch nicht?
SALLY: Hat dir bisher alles geschmeckt,
was ich gemacht habe, oder gab es irgendwas,
wo du sagst: "Boah, nee, das war jetzt nicht so meins"?
[Herzschlag]
LINUS: Nee, es war alles gut.
Nur manchmal sind mir so Torten zu mächtig.
Manchmal.
Sally: Ja.
Manchmal auch zu viele Torten.
LINUS: Die schmecken super,
aber dann würde man eigentlich gern mehr davon essen,
aber es geht nicht.
SALLY: Ja, ja. Es ist halt auch,
wenn man am Tag so fünf Torten mal kriegt dann...
Aber du kannst es ja vertragen.
LINUS: Oh!
SALLY: Gell?
LINUS: Ich ziehe eigentlich den Bauch ein die ganze Zeit.
SALLY: Ich auch.
Warum hast du eine Schürze an?
LINUS: Ja, ich wollte mich dir natürlich optisch anpassen.
Ich muss ja ins Video passen.
Nee, wenn ich ehrlich bin,
habe ich vielleicht einen Kaffeefleck auf dem T-Shirt.
SALLY: Vielleicht.
LINUS: Vielleicht.
SALLY: Also kann man Kaffeeflecken
gut mit einer Schürze kaschieren.
Okay. Also schnapp dir ein Eis.
LINUS: Woah! Das sieht ja echt...
SALLY: Ich muss sagen, das Eis,
LINUS: Genial!
SALLY: das wird gerade ein bisschen feucht hier,
weil einfach die Umgebungsluft sehr feucht ist
und dann kondensiert das natürlich,
das Wasser am Eis.
Und deswegen hat das jetzt so kleine Schweißperlen.
Aber ansonsten ist die Kuvertüre echt perfekt gelungen.
Morgens halb zehn in Deutschland
mit einem Eis.
Oh!
Gut, nicht wie in der Werbung.
LINUS: Auf jeden Fall schön knackig.
SALLY: Ja, nicht?
LINUS: Hm.
Mmh!
Lecker!
SALLY: Oh!
Mmh!
LINUS: Mmh!
Sehr, sehr gut schokoladig.
SALLY: Kinder Pingui.
LINUS: Kinder Pingui.
SALLY: Schmeckst du es raus?
LINUS: Ja, doch, schon.
SALLY: Es könnte aber auch so Stracciatella sein, gell?
LINUS: Ja, es ist halt so die Mischung aus Milch und Schoko.
Das erinnert an Stracciatella,
SALLY: Hm.
LINUS: aber auch an Kinder Pingui.
Das war ja früher immer das Highlight,
wenn es daheim Kinder Pingui gab.
SALLY: Hm. Oh! Warst du Team
Milchschnitte oder Kinder Pingui?
LINUS: Kinder Pingui, volle Kanne.
SALLY: Ich auch.
LINUS: 100 Prozent.
SALLY: Knoppers oder Hanuta?
LINUS: Schwierig. Eher Hanuta.
SALLY: Ich bin eher Knoppers.
Ach, ich mag auch beides. Ach!
LINUS: Aber Kinder Pingui.
SALLY: Aber es war immer so der Vergleich
Milchschnitte/Pingui und Knoppers/Hanuta.
Ja. Oder? Was gab es noch?
Gell? Das war schon so.
LINUS: Es gab noch...
Duplo war noch so ein Ding.
SALLY: Die wohl längste Praline der Welt.
LINUS: Genau. Ja.
SALLY: Was für Werbesprüche einem da immer einfallen.
Oh, krass!
Ihr könnt ja auch mal schreiben,
ob ihr Team Hanuta oder Knoppers seid
oder ob ihr Team Milchschnitte/Pingui seid,
also was von beidem.
Schreibt es gerne in die Kommentare.
Falls ihr mehr Eisrezepte sehen wollt,
dann auch gerne kommentieren.
Ich habe ja natürlich auch schon einige auf meinem Kanal.
Ich hatte auch mal ein Joghurteis gemacht mit Aprikosen.
War auch sehr, sehr lecker.
Damals hat der Opa Bernd probiert.
Das ist auch ein sehr lustiges Video.
Da war noch der Bürgermeister da an dem Tag
aus Oberndorf.
Das war schon ziemlich witzig. Ja.
Witzig! Man nennt dich oben doch auch Bürgermeister.
LINUS: Ja, sie nennen mich Bürgermeister.
SALLY: Ja, dieses Sally-Team, dieses verrückte.
Na ja, mich nennen sie auch "die Verrückte" manchmal.
Ich habe übrigens angefangen, montagmorgens,
um schön wach zu werden, damit alle motiviert sind,
gibt es immer Bewegungsspiele.
Und zwar kommt das daher
– ach, egal. Ich erzähle es euch im Podcast.
Ja. Bis zum nächsten Mal!
Tschüss!
LINUS: Tschüss!
SALLY: Und das Rezept gibt es natürlich wie immer
in meiner App und auf dem Blog, auf sallys-blog.de.
Head, shoulders, knees and toes, knees and toes!
[Musik]